hello everyone uh this week marks the
20th anniversary actually of the 9 11
attacks to mark the occasion we've
spoken to the very first new york fire
chief to arrive at the scene of the
world trade center attacks chief
joseph pfeiffer told me the harrowing
story of how that momentous day unfolded
as you'll hear it began with his 5
battalion investigating a simple gas
leak report be prepared this is a
harrowing encounter
we were at a odor of gas in the street a
routine emergency um nothing to get too
excited about since we weren't getting
any
any indications that we did have a gas
leak
and then all of a sudden we heard a loud
noise of a plane coming overhead
and you never hear planes in manhattan
because of the tall buildings
and then i saw this plane flying at a
very low altitude
and an extremely fast speed
that zoomed past us
and then i saw the plane aim
and
crash into the north tower of the world
trade center every first responder
firefighters police officers emts and
paramedics
every one of them
saw the burning towers
and even though this this is our job
they made a personal decision to go into
danger
because we all knew
we were going to the most dangerous fire
of our lives
17 minutes after the first plane hit we
heard another loud
noise of of racing jet engines almost
like a fighter jet it sounded like
um and this was the second plane
that crashed into the south tower
so now we have
two 110 story buildings
on fire
and thousands of people
in the greatest moment of need
the planes were deliberately chosen to
be hijacked because they were due to fly
to various airports in california as a
result they had an awful lot of jet fuel
on them that's why the buildings burned
so ferociously for such a long time
when the fire officers were coming down
i think you were engine 33 many many
other fire officers from all around the
area coming down to try to help when you
were sending them into those buildings
did you have any concept
of what was going to happen
the plan was
to
since we had no elevators working
to send the firefighters up
and i told them
to
do two things one
to evacuate the building
and then two will regroup on the upper
floors
to rescue those that couldn't get out
was that a scene
of calmness or chaos can you can you
take us back and tell us what it was
like
the lobby where we set up our command
post
for the north tower
there was spoken glass everywhere
there was cracked marble
falling off the wall
and the firefighters came in quietly
they didn't say a lot and that's unusual
for firefighters they
like to talk
um
but they came in quietly except for the
banging of some of the tools
um
they had a grim look on their face
because they knew they were going to the
most hazardous fire
of their lives
and
that morning
not only did we
we were concerned about the fires
but as the fires spread
we heard another noise
and that was
people jumping
and they landed on
a canopy over the front of the
the the entrance to the lobby
with a loud thud
and we knew that each thud
was the end of a life
and then at one moment i got so
frustrated that i got on the pa system
and i told them i told people if at all
possible hang on we're coming up for you
but i only could imagine
what a decision that they had to make
between burning
or jumping
your brother kevin also a firefighter
he came to join you didn't he um at the
north tower
can you tell us what happened next
a little bit before nine o'clock
my brother kevin
uh from engine 33 he was a lieutenant in
engine 33
he reported into me
and i can remember
we looked at each other
and we had a concerned look on
on on his face
and we worried
whether each of us was going to be okay
and he didn't say a word
we just had a moment
of
understanding that this was going to be
a tough day did you at any stage there
uh chief think
i don't want him to go into this tower i
want him to stay here with me i treated
him as i did
my other
brother and sister firefighters
um i worried about him
i worried about
about the other
firefighters
and i gave my brother
as well the uh the other
fire officers that
came in
to go up
go up evacuate and then rescue those
that were trapped
all the while people were flooding down
the stairwells and trying to get out the
elevators weren't working the jet fuel
had come down the elevator shafts it was
setting fire to floors left right and
center
did it become more and more chaotic in
the lobbies what was happening then and
what were the comms like
people came down
and they were very orderly
as firefighters were going up
the narrow stairs people were coming
down
and the firefighters did some
ordinary things
they said
to the people coming down don't stop you
can make it out of here keep going
and we know from
people who survived
those simple words
made the difference
and and
perhaps that's the reason
that i chose for my memoirs
the title of ordinary heroes
because at this extraordinary time in
history
our firefighters
did ordinary things
to make a difference between life and
death
when they started to collapse when the
south tower collapsed first although
that was the second one to be hit and
then the north tower collapsed about
half an hour after that where were you
and and what did you do
at 9 59
we heard a loud rumbling sound
and if you were watching it on a
newscast
you saw that that was
the south tower collapsing
i had no idea that that a whole building
was falling to the ground i thought part
of the elevator debris was coming down
the elevator shaft or part of the plane
fell off and was crashing through the
windows in the lobby
but the lobby goes completely black
where
we couldn't see anything
and at that point we knew we couldn't
command any
longer and i got on my radio
and i said
command to all units in tower one
evacuate the building
and they started to come down
our firefighters
then what happened
then
29 minutes later
i made it out to the street
standing in front of the north tower
and we hear a rumbling sound again
and this time somebody yelled the
building is collapsing
and we started to run
however with helmet and bunker coat
pants and and boots
you don't run
too far or too fast
in 11 seconds
and then this beautiful summer morning
full of sunshine
it goes completely black
where we couldn't see a thing
and then that all that noise from the
crashing steel and concrete
goes silent
it was like a new snowfall
this muffled
sound of silence
and for a few seconds
we wondered if we were still alive
and what would you like um the people
um of the united kingdom and indeed
around the world what would you like
them to be thinking
i would like people to remember
not just the collapse and the tragedy
but also
the sense of unity that we felt
i can hear you the rest of the world
hears you
and the people
that we were in this together
um
and and i'd like them to take
that that that feeling
of of of unity
and see if we could apply it to today's
fragmented world
and then
i like especially the young people
as they look at it maybe for the first
time
that they think of
they think of heroes
not as super superheroes of
but rather
of ordinary heroes
of a person
they can become someday to make a
difference
in other people's lives